Everybody's gone!
Look, honey, this summer is gonna be great.
You're going to make friends.
There's nothing to worry about.
Welcome to the Rim of the World Adventure Camp.
Alex. I am your leader, Logan.
I love you.
Mom!
Hey, Zhenzhen!
Where are you going?
I don't think we should wander this far.
Maybe we should head back?
Follow me.
What was that?
Never seen anything like them.
It's Independence Day.
It's June, Gabriel!
You need to wait here
until the adults realize they left us.
Go! Run!
Did you see the size of that thing?
Stop talking.
Please stop.
Was that an alien?
Let's go!
It has the dog!
We need to find our parents.
We got to get to the city.
Do not move!
We're at war.
You're not safe here.
You'd better go.
We can't leave you!
Take this key.
It's on you now.
This is a crypto-key.
It can activate our satellite defense.
We should try to find JPL.
It's a NASA facility 70 miles away from here.
How are we supposed to go 70 miles?
1973 Ford Mustang Mach 1.
I can't drive a stick.
Yeah, Zhenzhen!
Hold on tight!
This is Animal Kingdom here.
Hang on!
We have each other,
and we can't give up now.
I'm your master now.
No, the line is,
"Now I am the master."
Okay, we really need to get you a girl.
May I propose a toast?
Crap! This is from 1969.
At least get fresh wine
if this is gonna be my first time, right?